you've said that everybody should do
combat sports
not fight professional no no not funny
but everyone should do combat sports to
what end
well if you want to be a well-balanced
human being i think you you need to have
at least what we call a blue belt and a
blue belt it is defined by elio gracie
as
you're able to beat a bigger stronger
untrained opponent
you should be at that level you should
have core competency now is
is that larger because you don't want
people to be taken advantage of is that
what you think is so critical
well you know what uh if if
somebody were to offend me and i and i
sit back and i don't do anything about
it
people will say oh he's patient because
they know i have the ability to defend
myself
yeah but if you have no ability to
defend yourself and somebody offends you
somebody might say oh he's cowardly
right or he's fearful but i don't want
to have to
i want to be able to have the choice of
being courageous or not i want to have
that choice
i want to be empowered enough to decide
hey do i get up and and say something or
just sit back here and
practice patience which is another
virtue by the way so you have that
choice afterwards